on arrêtait l'once alors moi je suis
quand même pardon mais et intérêts
atterré d'entendre un élu de la
république capitulé face au trafic de
drogue
parce que c'est ça en fait c'est ce
qu'on fait c'est mon opinion c'est à
dire non je vais finir s'il vous plaît
monsieur moreau je connais votre
argumentaire par coeur je l'aï entendu
multiples fois d'une part vous expliquez
que parce que on va autoriser on va
pouvoir faire de la prévention
c'est pas vrai on peut tout à fait faire
de la prévention tout en gardant les
choses interdites
d'ailleurs votre gouvernement et
j'invite tous les jeunes qui nous
regardent aller sur drogue points
gouv.fr parce qu'il y avait un message
de prévention qui sont très importants
et qui remettent en avant tout ce qui a
été dit notamment par yann moix avec les
dangers du cannabis mais ça marche
notamment chez les jeunes la réparation
lorsque c'est un mélange pouvez pas vous
devez vous n'avez pas comprendre mon
raisonnement je pense et je pense que
c'est important quand même de se dire
que si on ouvre cette porte déjà le
message qui est passé aux jeunes c'est
de se dire mais écoutez quand on
n'arrive pas à vous faire appliquer
quelque chose qui est bon pour battre
santé eh ben on renonce premier message
qui est très négatif quel qui ici a
envie de voir son ado rentrée avec un
joint à la bouche à la maison dit loin
qui vous avez envie
premier des sept portes
si on ouvre cette porte et la porte
ouverte au reste pourquoi pas la cocaïne
et ses dérapages je pense que vraiment
d'ouvrir ce débat pourquoi pour moi le
message qui passaient la jeunesse et aux
parents et aux policiers qui eux se
battent tous les jours pour justement
enrayer les trafics de drogue parce que
les gens qui vendent du cannabis ne
vendent pas que du cannabis folles vont
continuer mais on va faire capituler à
vendre de la drogue de toute façon ça
tous les sens rentrer chez eux des
joints tu le vends pas abandonné il faut
oui de la prévention mais il faut
continuer la répression est vraiment
aller contre ces trafiquants de drogue
et des défis sont trafiquants de
beaucoup d'eau c'est très rare que je
sois sur le même plateau qu'un
représentant de la france insoumise donc
je passe la parole et pour la
légalisation
d'abord je voudrais souligner que mon
point de vue est d'abord un point de vue
de maman d'ados qui a effectivement on
était des consommatrices de cannabis
alors même qu'elles étaient mineures
elles ne le sont plus aussi nombreux à
la limite peut-être dans certaines
familles sauf que chez moi moi j'ai
jamais été trop dans ce délire bien
tenté ya match mais une fois il n'en
demeure pas moins que du coup j'ai une
sensibilité très particulière à cette
question de santé publique et notamment
celle des mineurs mon deuxième point
d'accroché dans ce débat c'est que
j'habite dans une commune de
seine-saint-denis où il ya de très
nombreux points de vente dont un kick
quasiment un rayonnement d'une de france
est ce que je demande à chacun c'est de
se mettre à la place des personnes qui
vivent dans ces cages d'escaliers parce
que moi ce que je ne supporte pas c'est
l'idée qui dit des gens qui disent ah
non le statu quo les policiers n'en font
pas assez
ça c'est parce que le deal n'est pas
dans vos cages d'escaliers et moi je la
majorité de priorité c'est que le deal
ils vont arrêter les matériels
voilà vous voulez le prendre chez les
bourgeois la télé on est là pour gagner
un smic à gagner le bol ou arrêtés et le
débat contrairement à ce que ça a été
dit par yann moix que ce soir n'est pas
pour ou contre le cannabis il est pour
ou contre la légalisation du cannabis
pourquoi parce que c'est la meilleure
méthode pour justement enlever cette
manne financière de l'économie
criminelle voilà il vend 12
avant ça un petit peu parce que
évidemment on est à peu près je pense on
est d'accord pour dire que c'est que
c'est dangereux que c'est mal que ça
voilà c'est comme l'alcool à l'alcool
les conséquences de l'alcool sont
terribles et pourtant en lisant vous ne
dites rien tu diriges depuis son abandon
mais le message est passé
quand on attendait parce que là on a
parlé des pollutions dont 100 millions $
pour ta santé du nominal à tulle nous
avons parmi nous selon le maire